pop quiz who is this
[Music]
if you answered Olympic gold medal as
freestyle skier Jonny Moseley you are
correct it is talking mostly hey I'm
Jonny Moseley here's another question
what exactly is Jonny Moseley doing
right now
it's strange it's as if Jonny is figure
skating unskilled what you are
witnessing is a rare glimpse of a lost
athletic art that was once the pinnacle
a freestyle game it had judges it had
costumes
it has fans it had a name
he ballet in the beginning dunphy saw
skiers didn't just want to speed down
they wanted to ski fun and they invented
a new sport that would eventually make
it all the way to the Olympic game ski
ballet was born yeah I just look like a
bunch of crazy stuff on skis this is
three-time world champion skier Bob
Howard a legend in ski ballet when the
sport was in his 1982 a day what they
didn't know then you don't know now ski
ballet is very difficult I'd like to
demonstrate my knees are shot so I
brought in Jonny Moseley I'm Jonny
Moseley they know ski ballet was a form
of freestyle skiing and it had a couple
different corporations it had pole flips
[Music]
spins linking tricks we put it all
together with rock-and-roll music early
on we did some moves that were basically
flexed tricks where you go off your tips
and what it is is you flex your tip up
and you spin around
those are pretty difficult because
you're balancing and you can hurt
yourself real quickly you can dislocate
your knee and instant here's Johnny
doing a 720 which is two times around we
copied this from ice-skating and then
even goes to a higher level where he
goes to a 900 which means he spins
around few times lands backwards the
length of ski ballet were never brighter
than when there was a demonstration
sport in the Olympics in 1988 and 1992
but ski ballet was not long for this
world
the spotlight did when the games dropped
it in 1994 and the whole sport was fully
dark not long after the DNA of ski
ballet is actually an everything that
freestyle is today all the spins eludes
you see in silk style in the big ass we
did all that and the very beginning
that's why I teach my students key
ballet moves I'm going to do film in
sauce that exploded
so the next time you're on a chairlift
and you spy Jonny Moseley down below
clad in a retro onesie and painting a
ski masterpiece on a canvas of virgin
snow take a moment to realize that your
glimpsing the flight of a Phoenix a
Phoenix called ski valet
you